Luke here at the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel and I'm here in the woods of
Alaska and I'm building survival
shelters from scratch I'm cooking
amazing food and we're doing some
extreme camping it's going to be a great
time come along with me you're gonna
enjoy this video
[Music]
okay
foreign
that's a footprint of a snowshoe hair
right there those are Snowshoe hair
poops and sure enough there's a rabbit
right over there as long as I pretend
like I can't see him he is just gonna
sit right there
there he is
just stopped to look back at me see if
I'm chasing him if you ever scarif a
rabbit just be cool and they'll usually
stop right before they get out of sight
to look back at you
all right we got plenty of dead wood for
our shelter and for a fire I think this
looks like a pretty good spot right here
I'm gonna build my shelter between these
three dead trees but I'm going to need
to chop down at least 12 15 dead trees
thank you
I need a little snack break
because I got a very Alaskan lunch here
okay if you haven't spent a lot of time
in the Alaskan Bush you might not be
familiar with pilot bread it's a shelf
stable cracker kind of like a Saltine
with less salt and it's one of the four
basic food groups in the bush here in
Alaska now pilot bread is a little bit
dry so you need something to wash it
down with and for that I like powdered
Tang
and if you go out in the bush and
someone offers you orange juice and
bread there's a good chance you're gonna
get this
got some smoked wild caught sockeye
salmon to go with it
um
all right got a good pile of trees going
here I need to take all the limbs off
them to do that I'm going to use a
Japanese NATA this is like a hatchet
with a chisel Edge bought this thing in
downtown Kyoto Japan with Tommy a couple
years back
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
so this is my sleeping platform and I've
got to be really thorough and go through
and take out every little knot and stick
because I don't want anything putting a
hole in my sleeping bag and I don't want
to have anything stabbing me in the back
while I'm sleeping so this is one of
those jobs that you really want to take
your time and do it right you also want
to get the edges of the front and back
log as well because if your tarp goes up
the back or you dangle your legs off the
side you don't want ripping any material
foreign
I've only been here for three hours and
the sun's already steady oh it gets dark
so quick up here
all right guys here's my bag of lamps
about five pounds of just lights we have
18 hours of Darkness here so you got to
bring a lot of lights and a lot of
batteries
and this right here is my box of
batteries so I've got 16 GoPro batteries
and a backup battery for my cell phone
and for my GPS that weighs another five
pounds so between camera batteries and
camera lights I've got about 10 pounds
of gear I bring with me at a minimum on
every one of these trips
foreign
I'm sure I'll find those in the spring
foreign
but the sun has sat and I'm running on
Twilight so I need to hurry up and get
some firewood and gather up everything
around the camp because it's going to
get really dark real quick
I brought along a couple Caribou hides
I'm gonna lay them down on the wood to
help protect my sleeping bag and to give
me some insulation this Caribou hide is
a really good insulator
all right
the hairs of a caribou are Hollow so
they make really good insulators
despite the shedding these Caribou hides
hold up pretty well I've been camping on
these for three years and they're still
doing great
all right I'm getting hungry I need to
cook some dinner
oh that dry dead Pine goes up like
gasoline
oh the temperature's dropped I'm gonna
bundle myself up a little bit
oh
we're gonna have some hot Tang
you know cold tank is okay but when you
heat it up it's like wassail or spiced
oranges it's actually really good
all right guys it's time for dinner I'm
gonna be making something special
I'm roasting lamb shank oh I love lamb
all right got that bone exposed got a
touch of olive oil here just want it
oily so that all the herbs will stick to
it all right we got some coarse salt
some black pepper
we're gonna set it over this fire and
just sear the outside
oh yeah nice sear on that
now we're gonna roast it Slow and Low
I'm just going to go ahead and add some
rosemary thyme and parsley to the roast
oh my goodness this smells amazing and
it sounds amazing
I don't know what it is about shelling
peanuts but they taste so much better
when you shell them yourself
I think it's a metaphor for life you
just enjoy things a lot more when you
have to work for them
all right I got a little Indian butter
curry and some instant rice to go with
my lamb here we're gonna start boiling
that up
[Applause]
oh are you gonna pull this lamb shake
out just let it rest here by the fire
for a little bit oh yeah let's take a
peek
oh
thank you
oh my goodness oh
that is so beautiful
I also brought along a couple pieces of
naan too because you know why not
oh that's perfect there we go guys
roasted lamb shank butter curry and naan
that is oh it smells amazing all right
we're gonna try out this lamb shank
that is so good I don't need lamb enough
oh just salt and Pepper's so good
uh Curry's good too
oh I am stuffed
all right I need to do some dishes
all right let's get started to get ready
for bed
foreign
I was getting into bed and I knocked my
pillow Into the Fire and I jumped down
and grabbed it but the damage was done
now it's got a little hole in it I've
got a little stuff sack my tarp came in
I'm gonna put my down jacket inside and
we're gonna do a little DIY pillow
ah there we go it's not too bad of a
solution gotta be careful wanna make
sure I don't drop anything else in the
fire including myself luckily I don't
roll around much I think I should be
okay I'm gonna put up this camera I'm
gonna see you guys in the morning
oh good morning oh man I slept really
well last night
I'm so warm in this bag
when the fire was still going it was
heating the platform from underneath and
it would just be this nice gentle
warming feeling coming up through the
mat but even with the fire out I'm still
a lot warmer than sleeping on the ground
I mean the ground just sucks the heat
out of you
being off the ground makes a big
difference
but I think it's time for me to get up
and build the fire and make some
breakfast
boots are nice and Frozen
oh I feel like ski boots
well this shelter worked pretty well but
there's actually a feature that's really
cool about it I didn't get to use last
night
you know that's not a bad shelter that
heat of the fire goes up and out so when
you elevate the bed you capture more of
the heat from the fire as opposed to
sitting on the ground next to the fire
plus here in the winter time you never
quite know what the ground situation is
having an elevated bed just avoids all
that problem I actually had a lot of
other plans for this shelter I was going
to put a wall up there and there but I
ran out of time but I'm thinking I might
come back here and keep working on this
project and turn it into a proper
long-term survival shelter but I'm
hungry I'm gonna make some food now
foreign
[Music]
all right got a pancake with fresh
blueberries in it not too shabby
blueberry pancake it's a maple syrup
all right fried spam and pancakes good
combination
it is hard to beat blueberry pancakes
with maple syrup
all right time for seconds here
oh
when I was a kid me and my family would
go camping here in Alaska and then we
would go berry picking and pick wild
blueberries and Mom would make blueberry
pancakes every morning brings back a lot
of fun memories
all right I think it's time to start
cleaning this party up
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
s on that thing maybe a roof I'm going
to seal it up all really nice and get it
super toasty but that's going to be
another video if you guys want to see
that video make sure to click subscribe
to the outdoor Boys YouTube channel we
put out new videos every Saturday
morning all right guys I'll see you next
Saturday
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching
[Music]